everything in life you can learn
if i know who your enemies are i know
where i align with you
right if i know who your allies are i
know how i align with you
and you've heard the sayings an enemy of
an enemy is a friend a friend of an
enemy is an enemy i'm you've this is not
the first time i'm
you're hearing this so who would you say
when trump was president for the four
years versus now biden being president
for the last you know whatever timeline
is that he's been a president
who would you say were trump's biggest
enemies who constantly got on his way
in his way and who do you think are
biden's biggest enemies today
and who they who could be their biggest
enemies so trump's biggest enemies
biden's biggest enemies and i'm not
talking about just china
or iran i'm talking about media universe
i'm talking about like
social i'm talking a little bit deeper
than who would you say are trump's
biggest enemies versus biden's biggest
enemies
well i i i want to just
go on the record saying president donald
trump was a friend
okay he was a friend before he was
president we have these great ceremonies
throughout the army navy game back
before kovit
right after he was elected he attended
the army navy game with my foundation
freedom alliance
right half the game on the army side of
the field half the game on the navy side
of the field with our with our
supporters and friends and our board
members and the like i told him then
don't be an enemy to yourself
unfortunately he never took that advice
he would call me up at various times
both before he was president and
afterwards and he'd ask me
for it for advice i would end it always
with
give me your phone because you are your
own
worst enemy biden doesn't have that
problem
biden it's not because biden is more
humble and
he probably is i mean there's not a lot
of humility in donald trump
i mean the the trial that's going on
right as you and i are speaking right
now
in the united states senate is proof of
that i mean the bottom line of it is
he became his own worst enemy in the
things that he would say in the way he
would say them
the things he did needed to be done they
needed to be done back during the
so-called obama biden administration
they weren't
they were being done by donald trump
which improved
look at one of one of the most important
things that donald trump did for america
was he created tens of millions of jobs
not just
a million but literally over 10 million
jobs
he gave people the dignity of work
there were people many of the minorities
perhaps even most
who'd never had a job before and they
could proudly walk home
in many cases the woman that they'd made
pregnant in or out of marriage
and he would hold up the check and say
i've got a job
okay very very important to the people
who supported him
very important obviously to the economy
of the united states
i mean the fastest recovery we've ever
had from a serious recession
it wasn't because of what obama and
biden had been doing in their eight
years
it was because donald trump came in and
knew how to work the system
and made it work so that other people
could find work
and get to work go to work bring home a
paycheck
the pandemic got in the way of all of
that the challenge that
presidents both trump and biden are
going to have
ultimately is what happens as a
consequence of this
coronavirus what what is going to be the
ultimate outcome of it
because if this vaccine isn't working
and the israelis are a perfect example
of apparently they've figured it out
they've got one across the board
apparently lord knows there's a lot of
baloney about
vaccines and my lovely wife and i have
already had our first shot we're going
to get our second shot here
on friday and so we're looking forward
to that
we got 18 grandkids okay many of them
are sitting right now around our kitchen
table doing their homework because they
haven't been in school in a year
and i'm hoping someday i can use my
internet at home because
literally they've all got their laptops
open in the kitchen table doing
everything from math to science to
history to your house is very peaceful
right now very quiet
i can already hear it the reason i'm in
my office is because
they've tied up back in my office
okay so so you said trump's biggest
enemy
was himself give me your phone put the
phone down you know you you you're your
biggest enemy
turn up alexander did great years ago
said i haven't met the enemy hit his eye
trump has his own enemy fair enough
let's look at biden
who's who's who's going to be biden's
biggest enemy because i don't know if he
has an enemy right now who's biden's
biggest enemy today well i i'm not sure
that enemy is the right one look i'm a
conservative you're a conservative i
mean you're an entrepreneur i'm an
entrepreneur we've created jobs for
other people
okay so i understand that i don't know
that he necessarily has done so i mean
i'm looking at some of the things that
he's announced in his executive orders
and and he talks like he's going to
unify the country
but we now have something that's never
happened before in american history
probably is unconstitutional and that
they're trying a person who's
no longer in office in an impeachment
process that says
the only punishment for impeachment is
removal from office
and if they want they can then say you
can never have another office never
another elected office
there's nothing in our constitution that
says you can impeach someone
who's an american citizen it's all about
office holders it doesn't have to be
just the president could be a federal
judge
it could be all kinds of people you can
impeach senators you can beach
congressman but no one's ever impeached
somebody who's already out of office
and certainly no one's ever tried that
person which is what's happening right
now
no so is one of biden's problems is
going to be trying to unify the country
that no matter what he says about it
patrick he is continuing to divide
america
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye